let's get one thing absolutely straight
from the word go I'd be thrilled to
introduce a discussion now about the
sensational news that Madeleine McCann
had been found alive and well living in
some far-flung corner of the world was
on route to being reunited with her
stunned but overjoyed parents
regrettably that is not what is going to
happen not today not next week not I'm
desperately sad to say in all likelihood
ever Madeleine was just three when she
went missing while on holiday with her
family in Portugal more than 12 years
ago to date Scotland Yard has spent 11
and three-quarter million pounds on
operation Grange the police
investigation into her disappearance
this week it was announced another three
hundred thousand pounds will be made
available now around a hundred and forty
thousand children go missing
in Britain each year mercifully ninety
percent plus are found within 24 to 48
hours down the years however thousands
of not no other cases had this amount of
cash or time heaped upon it there appear
to be no new hot leads to follow in the
Macan case in 2017 to 18 detectives went
to Portugal just twice so it is with a
heavy heart I have to say enough is
tragically enough unless there's
compelling evidence that can be swiftly
followed this must end the pledges am i
being repugnant or realistic NIC this is
one of those really difficult
conversations I'm a parent of a
two-year-old and if I were the parent
I'd keep taking the money but obviously
I'm not in this case I thank God thank
for the universe I'm not the parent in
this case where this has happened and I
see the point you're making there are
there are issues over the years of class
that I've come into this are they're
justified issues I suspect I suspect
that charlene downes case in and just
remind the list of us she lost a child
and she's very vocal about that because
she's working-class she isn't getting
the attention she complains that there
are other children who are missing
weren't getting the funds now if I were
the parents I'd keep taking the money
and
to hell with your social critique this
is my child we're talking about but I'm
not the parent here and I think in
because of that if we were to take a
third party you know cold facts in the
cold light of day take the factor
analysis it does seem like this has gone
on and on with more and more money being
put into it and it doesn't seem to be
getting any nearer as tragic as it is to
being solved just go to there the form
of Scotland Yard detective Collins
Sutton because actually as we generally
all know that if case isn't handled
properly in the first 24 hours
then it is just lost and this is
precisely his point here where we are
now I would be saying we need to start
this again for the beginning and look
good absolutely everything because
unless that's done I fear the squad
investigation would just peter out and
we may never know so are you saying that
the past six years and 12 million pounds
has all been a waste I suppose I am
because we're not really any further
forward we're not any closer now to
knowing what happened to Madeleine on
that night so you heard it there he's
saying it's been a waste of money and I
think instead of starting again I think
that actually is evidence for why we
should just stop probably you know you
mentioned is very angry very angry that
other children Charlene and so many
others are being forgotten a child goes
missing in the UK every three minutes
what about all those others who never
come home again and she's right you know
parents you know when I say the McCanns
are looking pleasing in a perverse way
they're having because at least their
missing child they know that every day
someone is looking for her all these
other parents of children know that
their kids have been forgotten but but I
hate to say this but no met police chief
wants to pull the plug on the model of
accounting and this and this makes me
quite close because I'm thinking it's
max more of how they would be judged
because they think they'll be criticized
for that then more than whether they
think what her chances are being Federer
because you know I think in your intro
you said it I think the chances are I
saw you nodding
sort of vision when I was going through
most of this introduction hood I think
this is very complicated I think it's
very sad either or release realistic no
I think there's something else going on
here as well I think there's the class
issue I mean I think if Madeline mccanna
be called Charlene and has she had been
the daughter of two shop workers she
would they wouldn't be the most
expensive and publicized missing-persons
inquiry in in in history but I think
that something else is going on and it's
that she's box office and this all
started operation Grange I think started
when a sort of when the home office was
lent on I think by a newspaper and it
all became no she sells newspapers you
know on newspaper website in in busy
periods you know at the time you know
you had kind of politics Madeleine
McCann sport you know she has been an
extraordinary a vector for selling
newspapers when the meplease had a lot
of money to spend on specialist
inquiries around the world and simply
now they don't if the media's been a
part of that huge part of it I don't
think it has created to led to the
decision to spend another three hundred
thousand but it's definitely part of it
well I think and I feel like I have to
say you know my heart goes out to the
McCanns and it's really sad and I really
feel for them and I feel like I have to
start what I'm about to say by saying
that but at the same time I think that
you are just being realistic because we
don't have an ever running tap of money
we have you know lots of things going on
and we have a finite source of money and
you have to prioritize is where you're
spending and what you're spending on now
obviously we're not privy to all the
details because I know that their case
is constantly under review and it has to
go back for its funding so to have been
given more funding one can only assume
that they think that there's something
that they've got nervous to pull the
yeah I agree with you and what I'd say
is the class sing to echo everyone's
point absolutely it's an issue because
if this was a set if this was a family
from a whole we've gone to a caravan
pack down the road and left their kids
in the caravan while they'd gone to the
local Boozer this wouldn't be getting
millions of pounds worth of attention
and funding and all the rest of it and
if you look at the missing-persons
website in the UK and how many children
children are on there there are so many
well in this instance yeah what I'm
saying is and I'll repeat again if this
was a family from home that had gone to
a caravan park let's just say Kenton
Bear Caravan pack taking their kids
there put them in the caravan and gone
to the booze that we're in danger of all
pretty much agreeing on this a perhaps
if I can just say that did that pose a
question and maybe Carol you can come in
here pose a question to you that if
there is even the slimmest chance that
we can find her shouldn't we just
continue with the case I mean I think a
lot of people a lot of these parents you
know what's the criteria for giving more
money we need to know if there is we
need to be told there's a properly
rather than them just carrying they I
think so because if there was a lead
surely they would have followed but
surely we would hear about that because
you know they come to newspapers when
they have something to keep it in the
news so till she's 21
she got returned 17 years later but it's
not because of extensive police search
it's because they'd enrolled her in a
school and noticed similarities and it
ended up like that and the same in
California's happen either question for
each one of you I mean if you were in
this horrific horrific tragic situation
would you still keep asking for the
money she would she Madeleine McCann
would have been 16 in May and I think
it's very touching and I completely my
heart goes out to Kate and Gerry McCann
and they write on a Facebook post
every year on her birthday and they end
this post as long as it takes just see
what the McCanns have had to say so they
said the months and years roll by too
quickly Madeleine will be 16 this month
it is impossible to put into words just
how that makes us feel there is comfort
and reassurance there and knowing that
the investigation continues and many
people around the world remain vigilant
thank you to everyone who continues to
support us and for your ongoing hope and
belief for as long as it takes right